es sind bilder die uns im minuten-takt
erreichen und die einem förmlich das
herz zerreißen zehntausende ukrainische
kinder sind auf der flucht sie verlieren
ihr zuhause im schlimmsten fall ihren
vater oder ihre mutter ein leid das
schier unerträglich ist und genau
deswegen wollen auch wir helfen ich
begrüße an meiner seite alexandra
würzbach die chefredakteurin der bild
gruppe und den ukrainischen botschafter
andrej melik dass ihr beide sie hier
sind heute alex du bist nicht nur
chefredakteurin sondern auch im vorstand
von unserer bild hilfsorganisation ein
herz für kinder ein herz für kinder
setzt sich seit 1978 für die kleinsten
unserer gesellschaft ein sammelt jedes
jahr jeden tag jede minute ermöglicht
spenden für kinder in not was kann jetzt
getan werden was kann ein herz für
kinder tun um den ukrainischen kindern
zu helfen
du hast es ja eben richtig gesagt wir
sehen seit donnerstag letzter woche
minütlich stündlich diese bilder von
dieser humanitären katastrophe in der
ukraine
und deshalb ist es für uns eine
selbstverständlichkeit von dem verein
ein herz für kinder dass wir da helfen
deshalb muss jetzt entschieden erst
einmal eine million euro soforthilfe zu
geben das haben wir morgen auch in der
bild da zeigen sich auch mehrere
prominente die uns dabei unterstützen
von kati witt über thomas anders bis zu
vielen vielen anderen prominenten und
wir müssen jetzt einfach sehen weil wir
wissen dass jeder tag und jede stunde
zählt und je schneller wir helfen können
umso besser eine million euro das ist
eine sehr sehr große sonne hennig wenn
sie das wenn das sind eine million euro
für die kinder aus ihrer hat was sagen
sie dazu
mir fehlen die worte wir sind sehr
dankbar auch stellvertretend wir haben
gesehen die schrecklichen bilder des
alltages in kiew in meiner heimatstadt
und wenn wir spüren dass wir hier in
deutschland in berlin
auf diese empathie stoßen dass wir sehen
dass diese schicksale der kinder ihre
eltern nicht gleichgültig sind nicht
egal sind dann hat man auch die
zuversicht und die hoffnung dass auch
diese diesen schrecklichen krieg der ja
seit sechs tagen tobt und jeder tag ist
wie ewigkeit für uns auch für mich als
botschafter aber dann haben wir trotzdem
zuversicht dass wir das schaffen dass
wir mit ihrer hilfe mit hilfe unserer
freunde hier in der bild zeitung im axel
springer verlag seit jahren eigentlich
waren sie immer an unserer seite und wir
schätzen das und wir werden uns nicht
vergessen dass die kinder jetzt auch
diese wärme spüren es sind sind
heutzutage auch bei uns liegt schnee auf
den straßen aber aber diese wärme werden
glaube ich auch meine landsleute auf
eine ganz besondere art und weise heute
spüren alex wie genau kann den kindern
jetzt geholfen werden was können wir was
kann ein herz für kinder mit dieser
millionen tun also das sind ganz ganz
viele verschiedene sachen die wir tun
können wir arbeiten ja wie du weißt mit
partnerorganisationen auch vor ort
zusammen medica und auch aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe die jetzt für uns
sowohl in der ukraine sind aber auch als
in den nachbarländern wir sehen auch
diese bilder polen ungarn rumänien
moldawien wo die die es geschafft haben
es sind millionen kräne auf der flucht
viele noch inhalt des landes die die es
über die grenze geschafft haben so und
erledigt hat gerade angesprochen wir
haben gesehen dass jetzt schnee
eingesetzt hat in bestimmten region wer
die bilder gesehen hat dass kinder nur
in hausschuhen mit dem was sie am leib
haben fliehen also da sind die
einfachsten dinge die dann natürlich
gebraucht werden die schutz gegen die
kälte nahrungsmittel babynahrung windeln
aber auch medikamente verbandsmaterial
das ist das was die kinder jetzt
brauchen und ein herz für kinder kann
geld dafür bereitstellen aber nicht nur
ein herz für kinder sondern auch sie
liebe zuschauer vielleicht haben sie es
gesehen hier oben in der ecke da ist ein
qr-code und wenn sie spenden wollen egal
wieviel ob es ein euro ist fünf euro
oder 10 euro jeder cent jeder euro kommt
an und jeder cent und jeder euro hilft
auch also einfach das handy nehmen
einscannen diesen code oben und dann
wandten sie sofort auf der spenden seite
und wenn das aus irgendeinem grund nicht
funktioniert obwohl wir es vorhin schon
ausprobiert haben dann gibt es immer
noch www ein herz fuer kinder.de und da
finden sie auch alle informationen alex
vielen dank das ist eine unfassbare
summe fällig auch sie haben die
möglichkeit noch einmal aufzurufen uns
deutsche zu animieren um zu helfen um zu
spenden hier ist die kamera 3 vielleicht
wollen sie einfach in ihren eigenen
worten einmal sagen was aus ihrem herzen
kommt was was die kinder in der ukraine
brauchen was die familien brauchen und
weshalb ist so wichtig ist jetzt
zusammen zu halten und vielleicht
einfach mal auf das nächste paar schuhe
zu verzichten und dieses geld ihren
menschen zu geben ihrem volk ja danke
nochmal an die bild zeitung all die
kollegen und kolleginnen die seit wochen
seit monaten unterwegs sind in der
ukraine um eben zu berichten um auch
diese schrecklichen bilder uns allen zu
zeigen um auch zu begreifen dass ein
krieg mitten in europa tobte und das
hunderttausende millionen menschen davon
leider betroffen sind und ich möchte
auch heute im namen meiner landsleute im
namen derjenigen die auf der flucht sind
im namen derjenigen ukraine die auch
weiterhin bleiben in der heimat die
ausharren müssen in kellern in schuss
bringen können ich möchte an sie alle
unsere deutschen freunde heute
appellieren helfen sie uns diese
schlimmste katastrophe seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg zu überwinden nur mit der
hilfe unserer freunde hier in diesem
wunderschönen land deutschland dass wir
so schätzen und lieben nur mit ihrer
hilfe können wir schaffen das trotzdem
dass wir natürlich nicht wissen wann
herr putin diesen krieg stoppen wird wir
haben ihn nicht begonnen aber wir wollen
alles unternehmen um diesen krieg zu
stoppen aber mit ihrer hilfe heute
gleich könnten sie das leid der vielen
menschen die auf dem flug sind die
bleiben ländern und sie können auch
helfen die hoffnung zu geben dass auch
wenn wenn wir diese explosionen mitten
in der stadt sehen dass das dass diese
hoffnung da im herzen der kinder bleibt
dass sie zurückkehren werden dass sie
sehen dass die ukraine auch nach diesem
krieg weiterhin zu europa gehören wird
und wenn wir sehen auch diese dieser
wäre mit dieser zuneigung diese empathie
hier in diesem studio da störe ich
buchstäblich dann kann ich mir sagen
kann ich auch selbst mir sicher sein wir
schaffen auch diese schlimme krise wie
sie können auf diesen krieg überleben
und es wird auch eine ukraine geben nach
nach dieser katastrophe es wird auch
eine ukraine geben die teil von diesem
europa sind wir deswegen bitte bleiben
sie bleiben sie nicht gleich richtig
spenden sie und helfen sie uns
das leite und und auch die sorgen der
kinder ihre mütter zu lindern dankeschön
ja und wir wollen jetzt über ein mann
sprechen der sich auch seit jahren
unermüdlich für bedürftige kinder
einsetzt und er sitzt auch im kuratorium
von ein herz für kinder und das ist box
weltmeister wladimir klitschko r ist
derzeit in kiew er kämpft zusammen mit
seinem bruder für sein land für sein
volk und für die freiheit ja und er hat
sich mit einem dramatischen appell an
uns gewendet aan zee aus dem epizentrum
des krieges
liebe spende für ein herz für kinder
es ist
unglaublich schwierige zeiten in der
ukraine
sind zeiten eines krimis
was man früher haben sich nicht
vorstellen konnte in europa wir erleben
dass tagtäglich
stimmlich minütlich
krieg bringt ein krieg bringt wahnsinnig
viel leid
vor allem für kinder sind kinder die
schon gestorben sind gekillt worden
sind kinder die
eltern verloren haben
kinder die zu hause haben
kinder die nicht in die schule gehen
können
kinder die keine kindheit gehabt
bitte spenden sie für die zukunft die
kinder in die ukraine
kinder die keine kindheit mehr haben das
sind dramatische wurde worte von
wladimir klitschko an meiner seite ist
jetzt irina l gehen schauspielerin
selbst geboren in kiew 1993 dann mit den
eltern nach deutschland gekommen das ist
ein landsmann der gerade in kiew ist und
sein land verteidigt und der gerade so
dramatisch über das leid auch der kinder
gesprochen hat was geht dir im kopf wenn
du dieses video siehst ja ich bin mir
auch zweifache mutter und natürlich mein
herz bricht wenn ich diese bilder sehe
ich sehe diese kinder und die eltern und
ich könnte eigentlich jedes mal wenn ich
das sehe weil ich das unfassbar traurig
finde dass
das dass diese menschen diese kinder
durchmachen müssen dass kinder in dem
alter wissen was krieg ist das sollte
mich sein das darf nicht sein und dass
es so ist ist ein unfassbares verbrechen
an diesen kindern ein verbrechen an den
kindern ich möchte dir und ich möchte
ihnen liebe zuschauer eine geschichte
zeigen von
157 waisenkindern die ihr zuhause
verlassen mussten und jetzt in
deutschland sind es ist eine geschichte
von 157 kindern und diese schicksale
stehen leider stellvertretend für 10.000
andere in diesem land
ihre füße nur mit hausschuhen bekleidet
vor der kälte kaum geschützt bilder die
die dramatik zeigen die diese flucht
begleitet sonntagvormittag in freiburg
an einem gymnasium fährt ein konvoi aus
vier bussen vor an bord
157 waisenkinder und 30 betreuer sie
kommen aus kiel nach stunden um stunden
auf der fahrt endlich raus aus dem
kriegsgebiet endlich in sicherheit
ich bin sehr dankbar dass sie uns mit so
viel liebe empfand wenige stunden nach
kriegsbeginn sind die kinder um zehn
jahre gealtert
die kindheit ist vorbei der krieg
zermürbt ich habe den kindern
versprochen wir herkommen dass sie ihre
kindheit wieder zurückbekommen aber den
ganzen weg hier mussten sie erwachsen
sind
denn die kinder mussten weg damit sie
überleben das waisenhaus in kiew liegt
voll in der angriffslinie der russischen
angreifer vergangenen donnerstag startet
die oder c richtung westen nur durch
glück entkommt der konvoi einem
lebensgefährlichen angriff der russen
in einer stadt reno das ist weiter
westlich haben wir gedacht wir wären
jetzt außer gefahr da sind wir von
drohnen erschossen worden die kinder
hatten todesangst ihr hättet hören
sollen sie gebetet haben gott hat es ist
grausam in kleine kinder schon verstehen
was krieg ist sogar auf essen und
trinken mussten die verängstigten kinder
weitgehend verzichten um unterwegs nicht
auf die toilette zu müssen einfach nur
weg einfach weiter richtung westen zehn
stunden stau an der ukrainisch
polnischen grenze dann quer durch polen
bis dresden schließlich die letzte
etappe nach freiburg wir sind alle tief
bewegt wenn man in die gesichter aber
gleichzeitig so viel sorge weil
natürlich der krieg geht weiter
krieg kennt keine gewinner und kinder
sind die größten verlierer und es sieht
man hier noch mal ganz besonders sind
wir sind total froh dass diese
evakuieren geklappt hat 70 stunden hat
die fahrt gedauert jetzt können sie sich
erst einmal erholen
bevor entschieden wird wie es mit ihnen
weitergeht
ja 70 stunden auf der flucht in
todesangst einfach nur weg und diese
kinder es sind weisen sie haben ihre
familie schon einmal verloren jetzt
stehen sie wieder ohne schutz und ohne
zuhause da janina du bist damals zehn
jahre alt gewesen als ep verlassen habe
das war auch nicht ganz unfreiwillig im
einen neuanfang ist immer schwer aber
ohne familie wahrscheinlich noch viel
schwerer
wie kannst du das in irgendeiner form
nachvollziehen wie es diesen kindern
jetzt gehen muss ich glaube das kann
keiner nachvollziehen ich glaube das ist
etwas was auch kann ja nachvollziehen
sollte aber ich natürlich ich kann das
fühlen wenn ich mir überlege
wenn ich meine kleine tochter sehe ich
sehe wenn ich das sehe ich meine kleine
tochter in diesen mädchen die da gehen
diese unschuld die sie haben diese
einfachheit
das werden diese kinder niemals haben
und ich
bin natürlich mit meinen eltern damals
geflohen und wir hatten eine andere
situation es ist nicht zu vergleichen
mit der situation in der diese kinder
gerade sind und es ist einfach nur
schrecklich und wir sollten alles tun
damit dass ein ende nimmt das versuchen
wir und deswegen sind sitzen wir hier
heute weil wir natürlich jeden dazu
animieren wollen zu spenden wir müssen
natürlich auf diese schicksale
aufmerksam machen damit auch die
menschen sehen waren wir dort gebraucht
wird und warum es so wichtig ist etwas
zu tun du hast sehr viele freunde noch
in der ukraine was bekommst du für
berichte aus dem land noch kannst du ja
mit ihm kontakt noch geht es ja so
schreibe tatsächlich über social media
mit freunden mit denen ich aufgewachsen
bin und
einer meiner besten freundinnen die kann
ich habe mich angeboten kommt sofort zu
uns wir haben noch ein zimmer frei in
unserer wohnung aber sie kann nicht
gehen weil sie hat einen sohn und mann
und sie möchte natürlich
mit ihrer familie zusammen bleiben sie
für sie sagt mein lebens nichts wert
ohne diese menschen ja auch wenn ich
mich hätte
ich weiß nicht was mit ihnen passiert
sie schreibt dies tagen sind in watt
eingesperrt und haben die spiel
abgehangen und
hoffen einfach nur dass die wohngebiete
verschont bleiben du hast doch viele
russische freundin wie ist da die
reaktion können die wissen die was in
der ukraine passiert
nehmen die das war und wie wie unter
hättest du dich mit denen darüber die
nehmen das war also zumindest ich bin
natürlich mit vielen schauspielern
befreundet oder kollegen mit denen ich
gearbeitet habe und habe mich sehr
interessiert auch für ihre meinung hat
mit denen auch geschrieben und ja sie
wissen was eine ukraine passiert die
medien auch wenn die russischen medien
nicht darüber berichtet es gibt ja eben
die sozialen medien die einfach nicht
mehr wegzudenken sind ja und da haben
sie natürlich auch zugriff auf all die
bilder und videos
sie können es nicht nachvollziehen sie
wollen diesen krieg nicht für sie ist es
einfach auch eine grausamkeit und eine
vergewaltigung der ukraine und sie sind
fassungslos haben aber auf der anderen
seite auch angst sie schreiben auch ganz
offen ja ich habe angst auf die straße
zu gehen weil
die menschen werden dann verhaftet und
man weiß nicht was mit ihm passiert wie
lange sie dann ist es nicht so wie in
deutschland dass man nach drei tagen
wieder rauskommen wenn man an den
demonstrationen teilgenommen hat sondern
es kann sein dass lebenslang ins
gefängnis kommen und dafür haben sie
angst und das ist natürlich
eine schreckliche diktatur wo menschen
nicht frei ihre meinung äußern können ja
absolut wir haben es gerade schon gesagt
und hennig hat das auch gesagt hoffnung
ich glaube hoffnung ist ein großes wort
und hoffnung können
wir nicht so einfach geben aber was wir
tun können ist wir können spenden wir
können solidarisch sein wir können
unsere alten winterklamotten abgeben wir
können decken abgeben wir können alles
sammeln was wir noch im haus haben und
vor allem wir können spenden und wir
haben es eben schon gesagt da oben in
der ecke ist ein qr-code also wenn sie
ihr handy zur hand haben scannen sie
diesen qr-code eine nannten sie direkt
bei der spenden seite und sie konnten
ein geben ob sie fünf euro 10 euro 20
euro von mir aus auch 10.000 euro
spenden wollen bitte tun sie ist denn
jeder cent jeder euro kommt an und jeder
euro wird gerade so dringend benötigt
für die kleinsten der kleinsten für
unsere zukunft für die kinder ob es
nahrung ist medikamente
all das kann dann gekauft werden ja und
nicht nur wir wollen spenden und werden
auch spenden auch die prominenten haben
ihre stimme erhebt so zum beispiel toni
kroos simone thomalla oder auch
stargeiger david garrett sie alle
unterstützen ein herz für kinder
täglich erreichen uns neue schreckliche
bilder aus der ukraine
was für mich als stifter und papa
natürlich besonders herzzerreißend ist
ist die situation vieler kinder die
nicht nur teilweise ihre väter
zurücklassen mussten sondern auch
plötzlich kein dach mehr über dem kopf
haben millionen ukrainischen kindern
drohen seelische und körperliche schäden
auf der flucht verlieren wir zu hause
ihren schutz sie brauchen nahrung
medikamente ein dach über dem kopf und
seelischen beistand ein herz für kinder
möchte den jüngsten opfern des krieges
helfen ich werde spenden tun sie es
getan ich werde spenden bitte spenden
sie auch ich habe bereits gespendet und
ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr damit
macht um eben diesen kindern zu helfen
danke schon mal im voraus
[Musik]